new details tonight about two murders
from may that happened just hours apart
we are now learning they were connected
police records show the murders may have
stemmed from an unpaid debt on a stolen
car arko mana is here after speaking to
one of the victims families and it's a
story you'll only see on 8 news now
denise and brian eric mosley's mother
says he did not deserve to die he and
his ex-girlfriend sandra cruz-lopez were
killed back in may and now mosley's
family wants justice
it's real hard to lose a son a mother
heartbroken celeste wiedemeyer says her
son eric mosley was a bright light put
out too soon eric was a
happy person mosley was at a trailer in
north las vegas on may 9 when police say
he was killed by antonio barry edwards
according to an arrest report for barry
edwards's girlfriend jordan monahan
barry edwards shot mosley several times
because mostly owed barry edwards 800
dollars for a stolen truck while
mosley's family doesn't know about those
details they're horrified by what
happened i know my son
didn't deserve to be killed
for
whatever reason that they say happen or
what happened the violence did not end
with mosley he was in the trailer with
sandra cruz lopez who was his ex
according to his mother police records
show barry edwards and monahan forced
cruz lopez from the trailer and into a
truck to go toward lake mead and los
feliz barry edwards is accused of
shooting her approximately seven times
including once in the head a witness
told police it was monahan's idea to use
wd-40 to light the truck on fire cruz
lopez's burned body was found in the
back seat it's rough for our family
mostly leaves behind several children
including this two-year-old girl his
family now searching for one thing i
need justice
i want justice
you know i don't want now barry edwards
was connected to these two murders while
he was already in jail for holding a
babysitter and a young boy hostage
during a police standoff in late may
both he and monahan are due in court on
monday live in the studio orco mana live
local now